the coronavirus pandemic has fueled
another crisis
an alarming surge in eating disorders
especially among
adolescents the national eating
disorders association reported a more
than
58 percent increase in calls texts and
social media context to its helplines
from adults and adolescents since the
pandemic started
more than a third of those are from
teenagers between just 13
and 17 years old center for discovery
which operates 15
adolescent clinics for eating disorders
reported more than double the demand for
its residential facilities in 2021
compared to 2019.
cbs news chief medical correspondent dr
john lapook
spoke to one of their counselors
elizabeth masoco she's dealt with her
own eating disorder since she was in her
twenties
mosoko told us she hasn't seen an empty
bed at the clinic since the pandemic
started when you are maybe
feeling sad or isolated it's
kind of those moments where it can creep
in and so
i think that you know quarantine has
definitely taken a toll
on people dr john lapook joins us now dr
lapook good morning
so we just heard elizabeth talk about
how isolation is contributing to this to
this trend what else is happening you
know especially during the pandemic
that's leading to this surge well this
pandemic has been so destabilizing for
so many of us right but especially for
people who have mental illnesses and
that includes people with eating
disorders you have increased anxiety
a loss of your normal routine your
regimen of your day
and a sense of being out of control
right i mean
we can't control covid but you can
control have the illusion of control of
what you're
eating until you said it i never thought
of an eating disorder as a mental
illness
yeah yeah yeah well so yeah you know
there's a lot of research into this um
it's a combination probably of
underlying tendencies like anxiety and
depression obsessive
compulsive disorder but also genetic
factors and brain wiring this
tremendous area of of research into this
but it's so important for people to
understand
that it's something that they can do
something about there's so much stigma
with mental illness and that's one of
the reasons why we want to say yes this
is a form of mental illness but
there's lots you can do if you recognize
well for example
early recognition we understand with
adolescents there's family based therapy
now
where it's all together the parents are
agents of change
and it really matters if you if you
diagnose this early
and that's one of the things that was so
interesting for me we spoke to
therapists and psychiatrists and
families and and patients themselves and
there was a 16 year old girl
who um a hundred pounds and five feet
and at the age of 14 she suddenly
started to lose weight um
she went down to 85 pounds she had a
good enough relationship with her mom
that she said mom mama i think there's
something wrong with me
and because of that she was able to get
into therapy family actually residential
and then inpatient outpatient and she
was okay for a while and then you know
what hit
the pandemic yeah and the pandemic
destabilizing we
we saw a graphic before they said what
to be aware of if you're a parent what
do you look out for here
well you want to look out for change in
your body image you know your unhealthy
relationship with food
looking in the body this 16 year old who
when when the pandemic hit
it happened again and she lost another
15 pounds she said she would look in the
mirror and
even though she was 85 pounds she would
say oh i'm fat
so unhealthy relationship with food
unhealthy relationship with your body
maybe they're going up to their room to
eat their meals they're being secretive
she said told me that she would hide her
food uh and then she would binge
and she would you know so she was
wearing baguette clothes at home so she
wasn't with her normal peer group
her parents weren't noticing and finally
they noticed again and they got
her back into therapy and dr lapu
quickly are these new cases the majority
of them or are they people who have
struggled with this who are relapsing i
spoke to a therapist about that he said
it's a combination of both so
in the case of the 16 year old she had
this problem she relapsed in the case of
a 14 year old boy who started
at 13 to lose weight he had been bullied
as a kid he was overweight everybody
teased him so he started to lose weight
well he lost like 30
40 pounds and his parents were thinking
great
but then he went too far and the father
who was so guilty when i spoke with him
he said you know i'm an educated man and
i have a graduate degree and why didn't
i notice this well
you know guess what boys and girls can
both get have eating disorders
and i think just the awareness of it is
so important and
and i i was very grateful to these
families for talking to me and to really
being so honest you're bringing that
awareness dr thank you so much such an
important topic
if you or someone you know needs help
with an eating disorder
you can text or call the national eating
disorders association hotline
at 1-800-931-2237
the association supports both
individuals and families affected by
eating disorders
we'll be right back